welcome to bit by bit a series where we
highlight one thing you can do to
optimize and potentially run a bit
better in Google Cloud today's topic
optimizing to start workloads fast
in gke the faster containers in a pod
can start the faster your workloads can
carry out whatever it is they're meant
to do using image streaming and GK
standard you can get containers up and
running faster in your gke clusters
so let's get to it
foreign
[Music]
we're going to compare the speed of
deploying the same two-tier app to two
different GK clusters one is called Utah
a with image streaming enabled and the
other clusters called Utah B without
image streaming enabled and they're both
in US West 3. the image streaming helps
us start our workloads faster because it
signals for GK to use a remote file
system as a root file system for our
containers this basically means that
containers can start well before the
full image is downloaded to the node and
it basically streams in data from this
remote file system as needed now each
cluster here has zero nodes because we
want to ensure our demo environment is
clean and so that we're not taking
advantage of any locally cached
container images so let's scale both of
these clusters up to three nodes and
because these nodes are new they're
going to mimic the behavior you might
see when Auto scaling an event in which
it's critical that workloads start as
fast as possible
and with those nodes now created let's
see what else our demo environment
consists of for each cluster we already
have a pre-created service type load
balancer with an external IP and right
now these load balancers are sending
traffic to nothing but they will send
traffic to our two-tier apps once
they're deployed and I wanted to have
them ready so that the time it takes to
create fresh load balancers isn't
accounted for when measuring the time it
takes for our workloads to be ready and
this is for many reasons sometimes
workloads don't need load balancers and
often you know cases of Auto scaling
load balancers will already exist so we
don't want to measure that today
and now let's take a look at our
container images that we're going to
deploy for our two-tier app that are
stored in artifact registry and now for
image streaming to actually work the
container images that you deploy must be
stored in artifact registry and the repo
that they're in must be in the same
region of your GK clusters or in the
case of multi-region repos the region in
which your GK cluster is must be
included and we'll include a link to all
other eligibility requirements in the
description below
but in our two-tier app we can see that
there are three container images one for
the front end one for the database and
one for the database follower now out of
the three of these images the front end
or app image is is the worst offender in
terms of the size coming in at roughly
300 megabytes we should see a
significant Improvement in pulling this
with image streaming versus without and
of course the larger the image the
better performance game you'll see now
without further Ado let's see all of
this in action
so we can see here we have our app
manifest and two services that we
already pre-created in the top right
pane here we're going to run a while
loop and issue requests to the load
balancer for the cluster with image
streaming enabled and then the bottom
right pane here we're going to issue
requests to the load balancer without
image streaming enabled and so we're
getting a zero zero zero back as our
connection is being refused by both load
balancers and when our two-tier apps
have successfully started we should see
a 200 for our HTTP code which means that
our app is successfully serving requests
so we're going to deploy the same app
manifest to both Utah a and to Utah B
we're going to watch which clusters to
tier app starts up first and gives us
our 200 and as expected our top right
pane has gotten 200s first which means
that our app is successfully serving the
requests uh in the cluster when image
streaming enabled and now almost 20
seconds later our app is successfully
serving in the cluster without image
streaming enabled
and so we can get our pods and let's
take a look at the details in our front
end pod to verify that this time
difference came from the container image
pull time
so if we look at the front end pods from
the cluster without image streaming we
can see it took roughly 24 seconds to
pull the container image
now if we switch context over to our
Utah a cluster and we get our pods we
can grab details from one of the front
end pods
and this is the cluster with image
streaming run the same describe command
and we can see that
this container image took a shade under
three seconds to pull
which is why our app in this cluster
started up so much faster
[Music]
the best part about gke image streaming
is that it's a turnkey feature that can
be enabled in your cluster by the
console gcloud or in your infrastructure
as code and as we can see here we can
use the console to update our Utah B
cluster to also have image streaming
using image streaming in gke helps you
deploy faster Auto scale faster all
because your workloads can start faster
as always you can learn more in the
links in the description below and we'll
see you in a bit
[Music]